Food Safety Public Health and private
arbitration courts many concerns remain
over T tip the transatlantic trade and
investment partnership between the EU
and the u.s. today Parliament's trade
committee adopted the text on TT that
maintains the system of arbitration
courts that asks for it to be reformed
to guarantee equal treatment of
investors and state's top carbon vienen
compromise ke phool that doesn't fear to
summon of me taco myself and managed to
Emma financier guten fake but some are
still strongly opposed to private
arbitration courts which they consider a
threat to democracy in giusti speed
apology a possessive okay da fare Kip
owed on Arizona des on trophies y con
cui kotaku volviendo justice dough
consistency private islas duties Aikido
no not capacity des idées horizonte
non-vegan more service public Elvis OC
00 d Tremont business lon sell business
we took national with the adopted text
the majority of em eps has given a
strong signal of support for TT it
remains to be seen whether parliament
will agree on a common position in the
next plenary session
you